[Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  what are you  I am a no God  listen not yet  you will be known at last for who you  truly are for you our Lord  has returned and the Southlands are in  great danger the Southlands  shadow  small and passing thing  it feels like the coming of night  the sun will set  do your part  you shall see it rise again elves and  dwarves working together hey and that's  how it starts  stay true to each other  our strength  Heroes amongst us even now waiting to  burst forth  I will serve I will serve  and tonight one more trial awaits us  I did not cross that bitter ocean no  need to draw  we are on the cusp of crafting a new  kind  of the Rings the rings of power now  streaming on the on Prime video  foreign  [Music]